you know the word haughty
haughty horsey
no this isn't an actual word this is
like is this like shouty but without the
S
so you've never heard the word haughty
does anyone in the office know the word
like h-a-u-t-y or h-a-w-t-y explain what
horty means
yes
I learned this world so dieters
he's literally the opposite of haughty
it's like kind of pretentious sounding
it's like oh God it sounds what does
aloof mean yeah I was gonna ask yeah I
was stuck up it's like pretentious Oh I
thought a Loof was like the best like
not thinking about anything like this is
the best thing about English there's an
exact way of describing the exact way of
an [ __ ] someone is there's like any
shade of [ __ ] the English language
has a way of being able to describe the
perfect level of like snobbery or
dickishness of someone what's what's the
two words on the two ends of the
spectrum I don't know it's just every
kind of word you want to it's like we've
like 10 20 different ways of describing
that someone is a posh [ __ ] right it
go it goes from the Spectrum for me is
anywhere between oh he's a little rude
to oh he's a [ __ ]
that's the Australian one that's the
Australian Spectrum sorry
the reason why I found this out is
because I
um I got an audition yeah I guess I
guess we have no don't start with me
saying to see
him just put that blur that I'll move
down the reason why I bring this out
yeah and to start the episode with this
because I didn't audition not too long
ago
um it's the first time ever happened to
me actually is that uh that you became
pretentious that I no no I've always
been there
um
so so
um I I was they sent me this agency or
production whatever sent me a audition
sheet yeah I get this a lot and it's
it's whatever they like hey can you
register for a thing and this one looked
really good so they were like hey we
want you to read for this character I
open it up and I had this thing that
happened that it's funny enough because
when we met with uh Jay Michael Tatum in
LA and Brandon yeah Michael was telling
us about a time where he had to read and
the reference was himself yeah they
wanted to sound like him yeah I thought
that's so [ __ ] cool that's never
gonna happen to me anything happened to
me and I was the reference
did they ask did you get the part so
hold on so but the thing was is that I
didn't never seen this word and they
were like sound like Sea Dog this this
clip it was me yeah I'm like cool cool
and that said it sound like this but
less haughty
and I was like what does that mean so so
what's so what is the so what is the
definition of haughty you know yeah is
it h-a-u-t-y or is it h-a-w-t-y uh
[Music]
shut up
this exact same thing as you guys where
I I you know I opened up the clip and I
recognize what it's from yeah I honestly
too much because I I didn't sign an idea
anything but I was trying to you know
good practice
um yeah uh is it this but hot but less
haughty and I thought what the [ __ ] does
haughty mean so I Google it and I'm like
am I I might be offended or
no I think they described you in the
perfect world yeah
at least at least at least they kind of
you know so soaked it up nicely in a box
so basically they said sound like Sea
Dog VA but take but take the corner out
of it yeah all of the corners
they might as well have just say that
just be a British guy but with a nice
voice so I took that as oh you thought
it would be like really nice all the
time like what do you like you don't get
a voice like this just just be less
haughty you don't get a voice like this
and not sound like that that's what
happens like you don't like I'm sorry so
I I you got the whole personality behind
her yeah you know at least you got to
give them credit that they at least you
know open up a thesaurus for this they
weren't direct about it they weren't
like oh yeah it would sound like this
but less [ __ ] pretentious and
arrogant you know like at least I won't
mean about it that would be the most
intricate way of insulting me start your
own like uh project cast a thing and
then send out auditions to everyone you
[ __ ] hate and then just link them as
the reference you sound like Joe but
less of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
they were really nice I auditioned for
the thing and I did I guess what you got
the park
wait wait wait wait wait they wanted me
to sound like Sea Dog VA you must have
been less haughty but less less 40 and
uh can you just like change your voice
to that yeah can you can you do it can
you do it right now
it's the voice that I would do uh if I
was an [ __ ] but 20 nicer 20
20. there's still that level of like
snobberness
uh that's so definitely that's the last
40 I suppose yeah so I did get the roll
I've read for the part uh I've done all
my recording for it's a lot of fun
um so hopefully that'll come out soon
I'll tell you guys when it is so you've
got to play yourself but nicer more I
guess so I wonder because I got a few
things that are coming out in the future
I wonder if people will be able to
figure out which one it is which one I
sound the nicest I mean when I when I
had to voice my own character in no
straight roads I think I have the
opposite
like play as yourself but more haughty
is that possible yeah
I've literally called musical.ly just
like you can't get anything
I would like to comment on your new
lovely glasses that you seem to have
procured thank you
I was going to say are you going through
your uh like art director phase like
what's up with the glasses also with
glasses Joey I don't know I just now
that now that I'm uh an owner of a brand
I figured I should probably start
looking the part
what's the next next
uh Mr Stephen no I can't I can't take
that are you gonna put CEO in your time
in your like profile bionics you know
yeah I already am I mean I can't lie
about that I physically am I can be a
CEO not a good one but I can be a city
yeah no I want to be a CEO just to have
just funny LinkedIn conversations people
oh yeah you've seen the [ __ ] they they
do on LinkedIn you see that one more
clip where the guy fired like a thousand
people on zoom and then yeah I saw that
one yeah yeah yeah
like he gave a [ __ ] yeah and it was like
a one-way Zoom call as well nobody could
take part like it's not it wasn't even a
zoom call it was a live stream yeah you
know what I mean the man literally
pulled up that that you know that that
the meme video everyone uses in in meme
edits of the guy crying yeah yeah that
one he's like the guy watched that video
before he went in he's trying to emulate
that it was so bad wait was this the one
where he phoned up half of like he
opened up with a speech about how he has
to let go of half the company yeah that
was [ __ ] hot that was so [ __ ] was
that something was that a different live
stream or was uh let's just have the
same one I think that's I think that's a
different one all right yeah there's
there's certainly been there's been way
too many Zoom firing for me to keep up
with nowadays holy [ __ ] I think
[Music]
and uh yeah and he said he's taking time
off because apparently it got to him oh
he's got to him this is after the whole
controversy happened right with like the
company or whatever no no no no no oh
this before that no this is way after
but I'm just doing pretty good now oh
really he should consider signing up to
better help that's that's what the meme
was so I wonder if he gave free
subscriptions to his selfish
900 people and be like guys I need time
for myself yeah it's like what you know
because like I always thought you know I
think and I think everyone can relate
but like when you hear the title CEO
you're just like oh oh that sounds
really fancy but then when you actually
become a CEO you're just like I don't
like that title I mean that's what every
CEO says you're fitting into your Roblox
guys guys I'm not like other CEOs no but
that's exactly what happened I am a CEO
was like I kind of hate this word now I
don't like it guys I don't want to be I
don't want to be someone of you guys
okay I'm one of you guys it just sounds
gross all of a sudden meanwhile puts on
the glasses and by the way have a CEO
yeah by the way see you all right could
you tell I got my business I got my
business cards right here got my
business credit card it's all sorted
don't worry